同学们大家好
从今天开始
我们要进入第四阶段
也就是实战经验的分享
接下来分享的是今天的韵脚诗
而这个韵脚诗的名字很特别
就叫做诗的语言
午后的风声怎么能被形容成一轮皎洁
花的颜色
又怎么会带着淡淡的离别
所谓忧郁的空气
落笔后要怎么写
最后一直到你的微笑在我面前满山遍野
亲爱的我
这才对诗的语言有些了解
是不是很特别
整段的诗句内容就是在告诉你什么是诗哦
你懂了
这个是诗的语言
一个想象的空间
诗就是文字世界里面所构筑出来的画面跟美
今天的议题是新人阶段的挫折与历练
一开始之所以进入唱片圈
因为投稿投稿
在我们那个年代是一个很正常的一个渠道
那个时候不像现在网络世界这么的发达
你想要毛遂自荐
基本上也就只能投稿
或是看谁帮你引荐
那因为我们在台北市
并没有任何跟唱片圈有关的人脉
所以我只好用投稿最原始的方式
之前的课堂上有分享过
我投稿了100份啊
很幸运的被宪哥
也就是吴宗宪注意到了
记得第一次跟宪哥见面是在1997年的7月
那时候我去中广的摄影棚找他
去见宪哥的时候
我还特意带了一张
当时他的专辑唱片叫刘鑫给宪哥签
那时候觉得哇天哪
这应该是传家之宝了
就是有宪哥的签名
后来就顺利的加入了唱片公司
那时候的唱片公司叫阿尔法
一开始我们就签下此曲经纪约1007年
那时候是五五分
就是说所有的收益是其作者跟公司各一半
后来我发现说7年都各一半
好像有点调整的空间也还好
宪哥是很好说话的人
话就跟宪哥建议
那可不可以
7年的时间
前面的3年五五分
接下来两年四六
最后两年七三
没想到新歌也很大气的同意了
这个是我非常印象深刻的事情
后来也就如此的签约了
我还记得那张图有两张纸
然后把那张合约呢并在一起
表框当成一个纪念品
那时候真的很开心
很兴奋
觉得好像已经衣锦还乡了
但是呢这种兴奋的情绪呢也就持续了一个多月
慢慢就消退了
为什么你只是签约而已
签约不等于发表作品
我是一个多月后才意识到这个问题
签约代表你的作品够资格进来唱片圈
但是不等于你有发表作品的机会
然后呢就漫长的等待
同学们知道吗
我等了一年
从签下持续经济约到整整一年
没有发表任何作品
你知道那种挫折吗
就是好像上了云端
然后滑下来
后来我就写了一封文情并茂的信给宪哥
对他晓以大义
我们辛辛苦苦投稿了
然后没有作品发表
那签这个月好像有点跟想象有差距
那还好宪哥是深明大义的人
他说好吧
那你就来台北上班
我就因为这样子去阿尔发唱片公司上班
我本来只是签约的词曲作者
后去上班之后才发现哦
原来同时签约的还有七八个人
这里面就包括了周同学
你有这么多人在等待
他自己就觉得啊当初不应该有那么多的挫折
就是任何新人阶段必须经历的过程
就是这样子
等待等待再等待进来
唱片公司之后呢
我负责是版权部门
说实在想创意我还可以
对于数字的处理我一塌糊涂
但是这些公司编自小
我居然负责版权部门
我当初的版权合约都是去跟各大唱片公司的
版权要来的
去跟面积
要去跟索尼要就是慢慢慢接触之后有交情之后
因为我们公司没有版权合约的范本
都是我去要来的
你就知道当初过程中有多艰辛
但现在回想起来是侃侃而谈
好像云淡风轻
可是当下真的很难煎熬
我去上班之后呢
我才发现说小时候小时候看电视剧
我就发现说诶这个领个公司包去办公室上班
我就很很困惑
他并没有制造什么东西
它还没有生产任何东西
然后就一个文书或是卷中递来递去
哎总经理开会喽
干嘛干嘛
我想说这骗谁呀
这这这能这个就有有生产力吗
就能领薪水吗
但是我没有办法理解
就是小时候国小时候觉得电视剧就是电视剧
后来来到唱片公司上班之后
才意识到说确实在办公室里面工作
是有生产出来的东西的
那就是创意
所以这个落差对我来讲印象很深刻
后来我才知道只有我一个是投稿进来的
其他的人呢都是参加一个叫超级新人王的节目
这个节目很特别
周同学是当年的年度亚军
他还不是冠军
冠军是另外一个叫黄雨勋的
后来一直到多年后
也就剩下我们三个人还在音乐圈里面
黄雨勋现在是杰伦演唱会的音乐总监啊
杰伦跟我就剩下三个人
所以呢有些工作其实需要熬的帮忙熬
然后当初进来的那些人
有些人可能觉得诶好像哪里不对劲了
就离开了
各位同学可以想想看哦
在内地的一线城市
5000人民币竟怎么活
当时的物价水平
其实在台北市也是刚刚好打平
就是房租付掉了
然后交通费付掉了
然后三餐就吃省一点
基本上也存不下什么钱
纵使这样的状况下
我还自动减轻
因为我的目的是要发表作品
不是要赚那个2万块
就是台币
2万人民币
大概5000
因为工作有时候是获取报酬
合理的报酬
有时候是累积经验
或者是说累积技术
还有人脉
还有履历
就说工作的回馈
很多某些工作你是要赚他的履历
赚他的人脉
赚他的经验
不是每个工作都一定要获取相对应的报酬
那时候我就跟宪哥讲
那宪哥可不可以
我的薪资就领一半就好了
就是1万台币
相当于人民币2500
因为我不想每天来上班
我想要留一些时间在家创作
因为杰伦有公司可以睡吗
那位置被他占了
我又不习惯睡公司
而且就觉得我已经习惯在家里了啊
宪哥是个很好沟通的
他说好可以
你觉得这样子适合你
那你就去做
我每个月领2500的人民币哦
但这样子的日子不久了
大概快半年吧
因为我重点是他发表作品
而且那时候杰伦刚签下慈禧经纪约的时候
还是隔了几个月
好像半年以后吧才加签歌手约
这些过程就是新人的挫折和历练
是一种成长的过程
所谓合理的要求是训练
不合理的要求是磨练
那时候我就想着这种心态去支撑着我的兴趣
而且我在想说
我怎么会辛苦呢
我是在我喜欢的领域里面辛苦
那这个辛苦就等于成长
而不是这份工作我不喜欢
那你在不喜欢的工作里面辛苦
那可就真的非常辛苦了
但是我已经进来我梦寐以求的唱片圈了
所以任何的磨难
任何的挫折
任何的历练我都觉得是一种成长
我就开始一半的时间待在家里创作
一半的时间在公司上班
新人的阶段本来就是这样子
而且还有笔稿比稿很辛苦
笔稿输了是没有用
稿费也没有底薪
那个年代的一种不成文的规定
就是签下此取经纪约
并没有所谓的授权金或者签约金是完全没有的
就各凭本事你能发表作品
那你就是有有能力或是有一定程度的实力
那时候记得中东学一开始睡公司
他睡在我们公司的办公室
有时候宪哥的办公室很大
然后地面有地毯
然后就一个睡袋就睡在办公室
因为呢他衣服必须送洗
他没有睡家里
那内裤不能送洗呀
一个大男生不太可能跑去厕所洗内裤吧
这是因为直接住公司
然后那时候新人阶段的比稿其实很竞争的
他就是一个melody
一个demo die
然后有时候七八个人写
就是唱片公司的版权部会互相认识嘛
然后互相互通有无
就是哪个歌手要发片啊
哪个专辑要启动啦
然后已经有一个旋律了
已经有音乐了啊
他就给你主题
然后再给你一个slogan
我们需要什么关键字在里面就给你
然后我们就很兴奋
一开始一开始很兴奋
哇天哪
我终于参与了唱片的某一个环节了
我就开始写写写
后来才知道哦
因为他要笔稿
一开始不晓得我们不晓得有别人跟我同时间写
我们不晓得几次之后就知道了
他就觉得天哪
原来是这样子的状况
当时都没有意识到
原来这个圈子像广告公司的文案一样要比稿
然后几次之后才发现说比卡中奖率很低很低
而且有时候比稿很惨烈
就是主打歌的话又是一线歌手
可能就七八个人和谐
你根本不晓得你现在熬夜写的歌词
会不会被采用
而不是像现在基本上百分之百会采用
最多就是修改哪个词会换掉
哪个韵脚不通顺
就这样子而已
你不会白写
新年阶段白雪的几率非常非常的高
但相对而言我比较幸运
因为后来我就稳定的跟周同学合作
就不用去外面跟人家厮杀比稿了
因为我们公司签约了七八个人
是去作者里面
我发现说别人的曲没有想象空间填的词
好像没有加到什么分
那周同学也认为说别的作词者的文字
好像没有打动他
好像没有很特别的一个语法跟视野
慢慢就不跟其他人合作了
我们就固定的稳定
他去沃茨这种合作形式就固定下来
所以不是一开始我进来唱片公司
他也进来
然后说哦你订我的词
配你的群的群
配我的词
不是的
是慢慢摸索
觉得别人好像没有加大分
然后别人感觉少了一点
慢慢我们就习惯说不找别人了
就就找对方
是这样子稳定下来的一个合作形态
现在回想起来
当初的比港就是歌词文字这个内力的强化
因为就算笔稿落败的那首歌词也不会白写
为什么
因为他没有用
没有发表
然后等到有适合的专案
适合的旋律的时候
诶
我们截取里面的比较经典的句子
会比较有创意的结构
然后再重新整理
重新写话
就一直这样子沿用
所以当初所谓白写的那些歌词
绝大多数后来都有用到
因为我是进来唱片圈之后
基本上所有的歌词都重新写
为什么要强调要重新写
因为记不记得我当初有几本厚厚的歌词本
里面有100多首诶
但是呢那100多首等到我进来唱片君之后呢
只有一首拿来用而已
就是宪哥的一张专辑里面的主打歌
叫你比从前快乐
结果那时候拿来用而已
其他我都觉得我先进来这个圈子的
我应该更自我的要求
我就忽略我之前累积的那些作品呢
这是多大的一种取舍
那今天我就给大家看一下
当初毛遂自荐这本歌词版的庐山真面目
好的就是这一本
就是这本歌词创作集
曾经在23年前骚扰了台北市各大唱片公司
23年前我们家没有电脑
我里面的字是委托打字行打的
然后呢装订的形式去大学旁边
大学旁边
因为学生要发表论文嘛
都有装订行
所以这个装订是大学旁边的装订行
然后里面的文字是打字行
帮我打的
我写在稿纸上
那这一本23年前的一个歌词本呢
就觉得充满了满满的回忆
这本歌词创作集呢是我大概花了两到3年
集结的集结的创作
然后进来昌平君之后
居然我只用了一首作品而已
那接下来跟大家分享一下
其中其实后来我后续看
其实也不差的一些歌词作品
各位同学看得到吗
华语歌词制造厂
这是23年前我自己做的一个
算是个人作品的厂牌吧
那时候我就很有概念
你的作品要变成一个品牌
那我就给自己取了一个品牌的名称
叫华语歌词制造厂
制造厂的概念哦
我想说我大量的生产
但除了量以外
我还要求指那时候我做的时候呢
我还弄个部首的索引目录都自己去编的
你看还有一字步
二字步
看到一字步
然后可能有首歌叫痛好不好
然后二字不罗列了这么多
然后这边是页码
就相关的页码
就是你看到这个歌名了
然后找这个歌就翻
我想说我替你想好了
就是我先有词的时候
我会替作曲者想好
然后我有歌词本的时候
我就替翻阅的人想好
说你不能诶
这个好像还还不错
那到底在哪一页合上之后
他重找没有
就像一般的书一样
我有索引的一个页码在这边
因为从事歌词创作
马上就要很细心
而且你的文字内容要细节到
让人家在阅读的时候可以在脑海中产生画面感
好那我先分享一段文字好了
这个文字可以激励大家的一个事情
23年前写的
那我这边写创作的路本来就多次
在机会来临前
你不能迷失
哪怕挫折一次又一次遍体鳞伤
也不停止
创作的路本来就多次
在肯定来临前
你什么都不是
只有寂寞在心里侵蚀
考验着你
坚不坚持
想看23年前
我就给自己这样的一个激励吧
一首叫情歌不死
我就觉得好自己当初写的时候
怎么想到这个标题
好在27
你看多方便
这首歌词叫情歌不死
如果不是最浓郁的蜜汁
幽谷的彩蝶不会离职
不会展翅穿越岩石
不会飞的那么坚持
如果不是因为泄露心思
亲人的玫瑰不会多次
我会开始对爱认识
我会知道痛的方式
有些感觉不能解释
有些爱情无法启齿
就让情歌在爱恨间奔驰
要唱千百年的相识
现在进入副歌喽
花开的日子
情歌不死
漫天飞舞着爱的种子
若在秋季飘冬雪的城市
落在红颜悲白发的人世
生命的开始
情歌不死
燃烧青春
写下的信纸
寄给落笔变气血的弟子
寄给碰触就断肠的名字
现在听起来好像还可以
但是我从头都从头到尾没有拿起来使用
我不知道为什么
就是进来唱片君之后
就觉得可能自己觉得啦
就好像以前的东西要要重来要推翻
然后再分享一首
这首叫1969年的忧郁呃
数学很好的同学应该算得出来
创作会让人家看起来年轻
特别是歌词创作会让你年轻十岁
我看起来应该是40出头
我自己认为的好
那我就分享一下这首1969年的忧郁
1969年的忧郁
有些悲剧开始于相遇
分手是早晚要上演的戏
爱人与被爱都是同一种结局
同一种的别离
有些相遇不需要设计
缘分是无所不在的空气
而悲伤却是无法被安排的
雨随时准备来袭
往事被抽离
向谁要过去
总是有些回忆
一些熟悉
不敢温习
1969年的忧郁
基本残缺的日记
过往的痛楚难以下笔
太多的眷恋来不及造句
1969年的忧郁是一种悔恨的情绪
多少年前的那位少女
你在哪里
我觉得最后一句有点弱
好
没关系
这个就是当初的一个创作分享
那我觉得说很有意思
就是这些过程你都历练了
虽然这堂课分享的是新人阶段的挫折与历练
但是现在还是有挫折的哦
而且我觉得有时候挫折会提醒真理
还在这个圈子
因为任何从事创作的领域
基本上你都会不停地面临到压力挫折
唯有面临这些压力和挫折
你才能去修正你的作品
你才能继续把你的作品的一个空间
或作品的想象
或作品的结构或作品的色块
做一个更往前的再次创造
赋予它新的寓意跟崭新的面容
这是每个人都会遇到的一个问题
所以呢各位同学听了我信任阶段的一些挫折
想想看喽
现在的你可能遇到的有属于你自己的辛苦
属于自己的挫折
那没关系
那就是属于自己的人生故事